you were dramatic as a child right very
very i mean now i'm an actress so yeah i
was very very dark and
tortured why i don't know i lived in a
nice house the nice family in the in the
woods i mean
tell us about this in the woods part
that's like a perfectly happy family
we're all fine lived in a nice house in
the woods
that's the part that sounds creepy it
kind of was if you want to break it down
i mean
it we lived on top of a hill in a place
called bryn mawr which now is a little
more built up but it's it's in the woods
we lived on a hill there were deer there
were no other neighbors
there was weather
yeah
you know
weather
weather not like here yeah no this is
look at it it's perfect uh oh it's so
clear you have uh you brought a letter
that you wrote when you were how old are
you was this eight years old i think i
was eight years old i recently went over
to my parents house and went through
their storage storage shed with all my
crap in it because i promised that i
would do it for like 12 years and i
didn't do it right um and i found a
diary entry that i think sums up who you
were at eight years old yeah and who i
sort of still am okay let's take a look
here we go i'm board board board board
board i'm still very bored take me now
lord
take me now lord no eight-year-old says
take me now lord i know
that's that's wow it's alarming yeah if
your child wrote that then you found it
what would happen
my agent would contact me
it would go through the line of people
and then it would finally come to me and
then i'd make sure that people took care
of it because i live in a bubble um we
have uh we have a clip here from the
show before we show it i know that kim
kardashian
yes was a guest on your show she sure
was she was she's in the uh the first
episode back the premiere as herself she
plays kim and the role of kim kardashian
yes and she was great at it yeah
nailed it nailed it
uh
all right we have a clip here from two
broke girls and anything we need to know
for this or should we just let it go you
know
i don't know what it is so let's just
let it ride
i like it
let's do it
just give me one good reason why we
shouldn't keep up with the kardashians
i'll give you five good reasons kim
camber
klondike
and the little ones crispy and cream
not even close but kim
kooky
kool-aid
and the little ones captain and kangaroo
it's kim corty chloe kylie and kendall
that mother has some nerve naming a kid
who's probably never even read a book
kendall
[Music]
very funny the fourth i can't believe
it's been four it's four seasons
that's nuts to me that's that's a sign
that i've been in the business too long
this seems like a show to me that just
got stirred and then you're here like
we've been on 34 years
well what do you think how do you think
i feel my youth just gone good forever
no it's not what are you talking about
i can't talk about it
i love my job and it's the best but it's
so crazy how fast it goes like it was
crying yeah yeah it does go very quickly
i was 16 when i when i started this show
i was 16 and andy was like 11 yep
started doing the show i was yeah we did
it in our basement uh